[Music]
yes so the talk has a bit of a personal
history my my former education
background is in Business and Economics
and then of course I started looking
into data science did the course it's
incredibly addicting at it more and more
and more and sooner or later kind of
people started coming up and said hey we
have this kind of data science problem
can you maybe help us out and so I
started doing some programmer consulting
for some charities and impact investors
and it turns out that the life and times
of often machine learning practitioners
often look like this the client expects
you to hand over the data you train your
model you validate you tester you send
back the model in some way they run it
in production and you're done and you
can go on to the next thing and it's
it's the same academia where people kind
of expect you to make an approach you
test it on a common benchmark so maybe
you do imagenet and then you publish
your approach and then you're done but
anyone who's ever worked as a more
classical software engineer knows that
it's not done when we ship so software
engineering is all about DevOps and
continuous integration and all these
kinds of things and machine learning
sometimes seems to have kind of
forgotten about it even though it's
especially important in machine learning
so who here works in a day job with
machine learning just as a yeah yeah
most people so the the reason 101 why
it's so important is that what we
usually do a machine learning as we do
supervised learning which means we have
some data X and we map it to some
desired output Y and we learn this
function that map's X to Y and our model
then is is this mapping function but the
water really is is this mapping function
in our training data set or maybe even
of
Aled Asian data set so we cannot really
be sure whether this mapping holds true
and in the real world
so then what usually happens you deploy
and the world changes so if you have a
model which maybe classifies cats and
dogs cats and dogs look similar over
time but especially if you work maybe
and finance or something
things change all the time so your data
might just no longer be valid another
thing that happens often is that your
model inputs your features are kind of
coming from somewhere where they're
being engineered so there's some other
engineer who who is working on that
feature that you're using the other
engine you might not know that you're
using that feature because you just
grabbed it somewhere from a database and
he has no idea that your your model is
relying on his feature and maybe he's
having another model predicting that
feature and then he's debugging it and
so that feature distribution changes and
suddenly your model gets into trouble
there might be unintended bugs and edge
cases in your mouse with things that the
model kind of struggles with and that
you only find about later because it
wasn't in your training data and finally
especially my home field finance models
influence the world you try to model so
if you think about fraud detection if
the model starts catching the frauds the
fraudsters kind of changed their
behavior according to your model so you
have all these kinds of things and it
gets wrapped up in this term of model
decay so you can you can imagine a model
like a fish over time it just gets bad
so well what do you what do you what do
you do about it
our models just a liability after
shipping is all the fun in the beginning
when you get to work with your Kerris
and tensorflow and get to come up with
all these cool icky textures or and
afterwards it just goes down from there
and you hope to hand it off to someone
else actually actually that's exactly
not the case because as it turns out
production environment is the perfect
training environment because your data
set the data set that you're collecting
is trying to approximate the real world
is trying to
represent the real world but of course
it can't because it has a limited size
and you made some assumptions about the
world when you collected that data set
on all these kinds of things but luckily
for you once you have on production your
model is exposed to lots and lots of
real data and there's two things that
you can do online learning which I'm
going to talk about in the next slide
but also there's this relatively new
field of active learning and which we
say hey the the outputs of our model
haven't have an influence on which
samples we should label and these kinds
of things and active learning recently
made it into the Amazon shareholder
letter which I found quite impressive
there they used it for the Alexus system
to bring the need for data down by a as
much as 40 X C that's what they tell
their shareholders so it's it's a really
quite powerful process but first active
learning so if you if you have a smaller
model you might be thinking hey why
don't we just continuously train it and
continuously update it and that's indeed
a good solution for many models the
downside is that you have a lot of other
things now to mow so how do you know
that you know model is not training in
the completely wrong direction over time
do you have a ground truth data stream
you might not always yea have new truths
coming in and it can be really quite
difficult if you have a big mouth so if
you have a big deep learning model you
cannot just keep training it all the
time and you might need specialized
hardware an infrastructure to train your
model and it's not the same so online
learning does not necessarily always
work what does work most of the time is
active learning so how does active
learning generally work is you take them
all might be a weak model whatever you
got from the data that you have you let
it make predictions on data that was
previously unlabeled and then you look
at where the model is less confident
about and then you label those special
cases and then you add them to your data
set and you keep
and the reason why that works is that
your closer to the decision boundary if
you imagine in machine learning if this
kind of decision boundary is separating
your classes you can imagine if you if
you have data that's very very far away
from the decision boundary doesn't
really influence where the decision
boundary exactly goes but if you have
data that's really really close to it
then
yet then you can shape the boundary much
better so that's the reason why you
should consider using active learning
and we're going to get a little bit
later into how and why you would do that
first when you talk about monitoring and
especially when you come talk about
production many people go like oh it's
like ops monitoring or we have similar
issues there's some distinct differences
which are yeah make it a lot harder
namely that in in model monitoring the
behavior of the model is inherently
stochastic and it's kind of dependent on
user behavior and you cannot say these
are the clear failure points and ops
modeling you can kind of say if it takes
longer than three seconds to load a page
that's really bad but if your output
distribution for example for your model
suddenly really shifts it could just be
that all your users try to classify a
different thing so that makes it really
a lot harder and there's therefore much
less established guidelines on how you
would do that I'm gonna link a couple of
papers later all of these papers come
from Google and they always worry a lot
about scale so it's very much biased
towards this massive scale um so there's
little ideas about how you make that
more modular so it's quite different it
has its own challenging and the first
thing that you can do when you when you
deploy a model is you say well let's
just run it to all the inputs that works
really well for structured data so there
you have kind of expectations about your
distributions and I think the next talk
is going to be exactly about that how do
you how do you make sure that your data
is what you expect it to be gets a
little bit more tricky
once you have maybe images or text or
something but as it turns out you can
quite often come up with with some
measurement whether your data is similar
for example you could say are the word
district
oceans in our text similar or the text
lengths similar all these kinds of
things it's it's much more close to two
hours modeling for images you would say
are the images bright enough aback
enough there might be something further
down the pipeline that corrupted your
images so this way you can really sure
be sure that what arrives at your model
is as what should arrive there and
that's a it's a more standardized
process the other thing that you can do
is you monitor the apples of your model
and that's a little bit harder because
there you have not made as much
assumption or the user users might just
change a little bit but monitoring the
outputs distribution in comparing it to
your training set distributional better
I get to your validation set
distribution is surprisingly helpful and
kind of gives you an early alert if
things are different than where you
expected them to be
and another thing to model is maybe just
model the confidence of your mouth so
that is something that works well for
many application way just say well and
in training our model was always pretty
sure and now suddenly the confidence
goes way down and maybe the state says
weird or something and what's a new
approach that some startups are trying
out is that you say we have to slim a
model which we run for most of our users
but we send a smaller subset to much
bigger model which has a better accuracy
and something or maybe to a whole
assemble of them and we just let it
check against those and then we can
maybe infer the accuracy through that
and finally you should try to compare
against ground truth and ground truth is
its own kind of tricky thing because if
you're lucky you have a constant ground
truth stream coming in so in in credit
card fraud for example about a few weeks
after the fraud happened someone will
call you and say hey I was defrauded any
model didn't catch it and then you have
the the thing the ground troops coming
in if you have a for example an app that
classifies images or something like a
google lens like product
you won't necessarily notice if what you
classified was not what it actually
should have been so how do you deal with
that my kind of little bit radical
advice is that you label a small subset
of your data by hand and your data
scientists should do that and data sense
never want to do that but actually it
turns out that if you get the UI
experience of this labeling task right
and then it can be much more efficient
and say using Mechanical Turk use first
because your label US will be much more
high quality and you can actually rely
on these ground truth labels to be
ground truth second if you're the data
scientist at work on them all also
monitor the data against the
classifications there will be much more
quick to find a buck before it really
shows up in in the statistics so maybe
they look at images and say oh you know
we get so many images with low lights we
didn't expect that or smartphone cameras
are just really bad or something that is
much easier to catch that way rather
than if you are if you do it
statistically I want to highlight a
really great implementation of this UI
this is prodigy it's a product by the
same people that makes Pacey I think
there were a couple talks about Spacey
and this one really it can be simple
weather but like that where you have two
keys right is wrong and then you've got
the error over time and maybe you take
turns and everybody labels a few hundred
examples it goes relatively quickly if
you have this kind of good AI UI and in
the in the theme of of going with UI
so once you've established your metrics
you keep tracking them you might be
wanting to do some alerting or maybe you
want to have a dashboard where you can
keep track of these metrics and it turns
out that is kind of fundamentally not a
data problem but a UI UX problem and
even though this is a data science
conference we have to really think about
who is consuming our reports and many
times that is not data science
so the classic example is maybe that
your model is going bad all the alarm
rings start ringing and you run into the
office of the CEO and say we have to
shut up down because KL divergence is at
1.5 and he will just look at you like
okay I don't I don't get you but I'm
definitely not going to shut down so um
it's really important to communicate as
well and to show you how this can go is
this is maybe an alerting example so you
you train them all which is their to
classify draw dog breeds you have a
couple of dogs in your in your image
some kind of app and this is your
training set distribution so there's
kind of an equal amount of all the dogs
in your training set distribution and
then suddenly you see this kind of
output distribution and how how should
you alert this how should you report
this what should you do there's kind of
three three options I could think of the
first one is you you measure kld
versions you shouldn't measure it
otherwise you won't know whether these
distributions are the same or different
and you could reports just write that
and as I alluded earlier that's kind of
a tricky idea much better if you frame
it a little bit different interest to
the language a little bit nicer but
what's even better is if you if you go
directly to the outlier you you alert
when the distributions are too different
but then you highlight this outlier and
you say look there they're way more
parks than we expected and that
immediately will allow one of your of
your team members to kind of quickly
scroll through the data that's coming in
and see if people are really just taking
pictures of their parks and if person
super popular or right now or if it's if
it's something else
so you have all this modeling and
monitoring kind of this just a technical
part to make sure that your model
assumptions are correct and I write what
many people that build models are often
tend to forget or or yeah maybe I'm not
as aware of is that they're models then
have real-world influences and that
ultimately they accountable for these
real-world influences and this is this
this means that for awhile we should be
able to answer for each individual
prediction who made a decision on which
garner was made and how and why it was
made
there's a few other talks of modeling
for each ability but what I won't just
want to stress is that we need to kind
of keep track of the individual
predictions of the individual
transactions to later go back and see
why they were made especially if we're
operating in a more high-stakes
environment so if you're doing dog
classification nobody will probably come
after you but if you're doing something
much more high-stakes like when we say
algorithmic trading or finding a place
for orphans then someone might come and
ask like hey why was this decision made
and with with that um when you start
monitoring these things you start wading
into the field of higher or defect so I
hope my slide is readable from the back
the contrast is not the best but what
happens is that you as a data scientist
are mostly concerned about your model
metrics like accuracy f1 schoo and so on
and the product owner whose product
you're working with is concerned about
user behavior like the click-through
rate and he will evaluate your metric on
his metrics so if your model that has a
high accuracy also increases the
click-through rate he will be happy
otherwise he will signal you to do
something really different and that
product down again gets evaluated by
your CEO who is worrying about revenue
so as you can see this this kind of
smaller metric or is out and pulls out
and pulls out and there's ever-larger
kind of circles around it ever larger
impacts and these larger and practices
high order effects to monitor those is
extremely difficult but not impossible
and I think we as a field are now just
getting into how to do that
because if you look at the at the top
rank to society and impact we have now
just seen in the last couple of weeks
that the malls that we build really
might have a society changing impact not
in the way that we intended it to be and
that only happens if you deploy them at
huge scale
so these large large impact be it
societal impact or revenue they're hard
to monitor um they're also tiny late
they only show up when you have scale so
if you start up and you start small you
might not see them and then suddenly
they're there there's extra genus factor
so that is a really open question how to
how to do these but there are some some
inroads made into that and the first
approach is that your users that come in
contact with thee with the outbound
decisions of your model often desperate
to improve your product because they see
that your product made something
extremely stupid so being good about
designing the feedback for the users and
being good then to link that feedback to
the model to the model idea and to the
transaction ideas I think the way you
are you can then refer back to how your
malla metric for that specific model
impacted the experience for this user
and how these higher-order effects all
vibrates it out and this metric is user
in user feedback it's kind of this
matter metric which you probably also
want to monitor in which you want to
make easy to collect you see that some
firms start adding like give feedback to
this thing thing of the website I think
that is something that as machine
learning engineers can hit hard on and
say no I really want this data on how
you just feel about this so to kind of
wrap it up I want to give an
implementation example because the rest
of the talk has been quite theoretical
at high level if you look at most of the
talks of most of the papers they are
made for big
very expensive but actually you can do
all this monitoring and with completely
open source software much of which you
will be familiar with so in the other
room there's a VESA token serving mouths
you can do that perfectly with docker
and flask and then the idea is that you
take those predictions and the input
setting will make and you send it to to
another maybe darker instance or to
another micro service which I like to
call the watchman instance and this
watchman instance will then first store
their transaction and through some
database and we'll also compare the
relevant metrics and it will give it
into your alerting so then you can send
it out so this can be done relatively
bare-bones and relatively easy so easy
actually that I want to give a couple
lines of code how you can do that so
this first code snippet is how you would
serve a Karass model for classification
all it does is request the image file
resizes it runs it through a Karass
model and then it takes out the labels
and it takes a dictionary and gives back
a JSON file so that is bare-bones
serving and from then you pass on this
output as addition to the input that you
get in the in the post request to your
to your watchdog instance and there you
can do all the statistical monitoring
more or less with cycads with without
many great modifications so this is the
example of the of the dog classifier I
showed earlier first you take some
entropy measure between your expected
output distribution and your actual
output distribution if that exceeds some
threshold ego try find the worst
offender so you go the the data model
for which the absolute difference in the
distribution is the largest and then you
can just report the the worst offender
the absolute difference and the mass
deviation and it generally creates a
really nice alert like their 50% more
parks than expected the absolute
deviation is this or is
bound by a factor of two or something so
as a concluding remark who should do all
of this generally the data science team
should do it all and I feel that as a
field it will develop more towards more
towards an integrative process in which
data scientists or data engineers will
be given tools that take away the
serving and the CI and all that kind of
thing away from them and they can really
focus on the data-driven things because
all these things are fundamentally kind
of data science tasks if you have a free
afternoon there couple unsolved
challenges which I would I would like to
get solved which I kind of left out
we're not really good at versioning and
data set versioning yet which are
critical components to this kind of
monitoring system because you need to be
sure which which version you have the
communication throughout the
organization is not as has to be
improved so we have to find a common
language together with managers how we
talk about these things and managing
higher order effects is is something
we're just starting to do but it's
getting extreme and exciting if you want
to do some reading these are kind of my
recommended reads on the topic the
lowest one is my book machine learning
for Finance was coming out in July which
has a whole shaft on the topic and yeah
thank you all for listening
[Applause]
yeah the question concerns extending
your data set with new labeled data you
set the interesting points are the ones
that the model is a bit unsecure about
yeah especially in perhaps regions of
feature space where you don't have too
much data this number could be quite
unreliable any thoughts on how to deal
with that yeah so there's a there's a
pretty large range how to quantify
uncertainty about something there was a
talk here early on Thomson something
which has like a Bayesian approach so
there's many different ones if you are
not too worried about labeling a few
more things I'm just and you have a
classification task take the top
prediction soft max output and the
lowest prediction software approach
subtract them and that's how you go and
otherwise you can do something a little
bit more advanced so there's many
different ways
or the dataset and modeling versioning I
can highly recommend setting up your own
get LFS server yeah so you can just keep
your model and depending on the size of
your data but all the data with your
model and at least if you want to figure
out how was his model trains just go
back to the revision and try it out
thank you any more questions
[Applause]